it's the final in the now very poorly
named Star Wars trilogy Return of the
Jedi everyone says this is the least of
the original three Star Wars films not
bad just not as good as the other two
and honestly I think it gets a little
bit of a bum rap not to say the
criticisms aren't right it's just the
stuff that's good in it I think is a lot
better than some of the stuff in the
other films but does that make it better
than the other two well let's take a
look Han Solo is kept captive by the
evil gangster Jabba the Hutt Luke Leia
Lando all tried to sneak in to break him
out but they get caught themselves after
several fight sequences and battling a
bunch of monsters they eventually escape
and make it back to the rebellion where
they find out the Empire is once again
building another Death Star only this
time the leader of the Empire the
Emperor will be on there for them to
take it down so the team tries to take
down the shield generator it's on a
nearby moon while the rest of the
fighters try to fly in to blow it up the
team on the moon comes across
inhabitants called Ewoks
while Luke separates from the team to
confront the Emperor and Darth Vader
himself and the rebels take down the
evil empire once and for all and will
Luke ultimately find himself turning to
the light side or the dark side a
fitting setup for a finale but the
biggest problem everybody has that I
have to admit I have too is that there's
way too many detours the opening
sequence with Jabba the Hutt and
breaking Han Solo out it goes on forever
there's a moment you can end it where
Luke destroys this big monster but no
they had to drag them to another monster
for him to destroy truth be told you
could cut everything having to do with
Jabba out of these movies and you would
miss nothing think about it you could
have Han Solo captured by anybody help
you don't even really need to get rid of
him that's just sort of leaving it open
for a cliffhanger he could have been
with the team he didn't have to be sent
away
honestly the Ewoks play a bigger part
than the Jabba the Hutt scenes I know
that sounds crazy but really think about
it the Ewoks helped take down the Empire
they play a part they serve the story
and it also makes a well-intended if not
immaturely done message of nature versus
technology which is in a lot of stories
and myths so why do we put up with those
Java scenes so much
well to put simply job as a cool
character he's this big fat slug that
just does whatever he wants it's kind of
the American dream he's a gangster and
he gets away with it so why does it many
people hate the Ewoks because one we
already saw a ton of puppets and we're
getting sick of them second their little
teddy bears and after the last film
where everything was so dark and gritty
what we suddenly got a bunch of little
teddy bears this is feeling more like a
toy commercial in my honest opinion if
you want to fix this Jabba should have
been on the moon cut out the opening
save him until halfway have him capture
Solo wanting his money back but then
when he finds out the Empire is in his
territory then he decides to fight him
off and help the rebellion how much more
fitting with that event Jabba would have
been both the bad guy and the good guy
at the same time and he would have had a
purpose and oh my god would it be so
cool if you saw Jabba's people attacking
those stormtroopers instead of Ewoks
also throw in a pointless motorcycle
style chase and all too similar retread
of the destroying the Death Star in the
first film and little teddy bears
throwing rocks and yeah you can see how
a lot of people would see this as the
lesser of the films but with that said
not only are these some of the best
effects that ever came out of the movies
but it has some of the most dramatic
moments the scenes where Luke is
confronting Vader and the Emperor are
some of the best in any of the movies
the guy they got to play the Emperor is
perfect he's old and frail but by god he
has such presence and this deep
crackling voice with these yellow eyes
it's almost something out of the
Exorcist at times his acting can be a
little goofy but it's goofy in just the
right way he's taking a risk that you're
in such a dark uncomfortable mood that
you're just going to accept that this is
creepy and for the most part it works
the whole atmosphere is just so dark and
so brooding and so shadowy you just feel
like you've descended into hell
the minute Luke walks in is their
prisoner the Emperor just gets rid of
the handcuffs like yeah we know there's
nothing you can do here and the longer
it goes the more we dive deeper and
deeper into the darker side of Luke's
anger of Luke's rage and the visuals all
support it the pacing supports it -
there's a fight going on but it's also
very psychological the music the
atmosphere the acting
dialog everything it's perfect it's
about as pitch perfect a scene you can
get in any Star Wars film but does that
make up for the other little mistakes in
the film probably not
but like I said before even though a lot
of it doesn't always connect it cool the
scenes with job are cool and yeah even
say the Ewoks are not as bad as
everybody says they are
they left us a mochi jokes and I like
the idea of wood trampling steel by the
end when everything wrapped up it just
kind of felt right when you see the
final scene in the Ewok village you just
kind of go yeah you know what this is a
good place to stop everybody seems happy
everybody seems in the right place where
their flaws sure but just like there
were flaws in the other films too I
guess I just don't get what everybody
says this is the light-hearted one when
there were such dark and gritty scenes
in it some of them the best out of any
of the movies so yeah is the first film
technically told better yes but I still
stand by the third has some of the best
moments out of any oh and like I said
it's just a good ending not the best but
still free damn impressive and for a
while this is all Star Wars fans thought
they would ever get out of this but
little did they know that so much more
good and bad was awaiting them in the
future